all right Ellen
Ellen no where'd you grow up where are
you from originally oh uh I was born in
um
Spokane Washington
tell me about your family
um
so I I have a older sister who has the
same parents as I and then um I think I
have
I know I have one brother and I and at
least two sisters that I don't really
know they're they have
the same uh bothers me but not the same
mother
and I don't really I met
um the little brother and one little
sister when they were really small but I
haven't seen them for and your parents
so uh I have
um
like I call him a sperm donor
he uh is still alive and that's where
the little brothers and sisters come
from
um I my mom
she uh and my stepdad Who I Really call
my dad
they were killed in 1984 I was six years
old
they died on Mother's Day they got and
they had on collision with a drunk
driver
they were they were on a motorcycle
going to put flowers on his mother's
grave and a drunk driver was driving
down the wrong side of the highway with
his headlights off and we had on
collision and killed them on Mother's
Day in 84.
so
as far as parents there's none alive the
the sperm donor
he's not any kind of part of my life
anymore what happened to your what
happened to you after that accident well
so
I mean I can go back to the recollection
of that day was
it was Mother's Day and I was sort of
mad at my mom because she was dropping
me off at her parents house I was six
six and I wanted to spend Mother's Day
with her it was really important to me
and she dropped me off and was spending
it with you know her new husband and
I was sort of mad about that
um they went to put flowers on his mom's
grave
on for that Mother's Day and I remember
waking up in the morning and everyone I
was in the in a house with my sister and
my mom's parents and they were gone and
so when I woke up in the middle of the
night and it was just me and my sister
would have been 11
and we were the only two people in the
house I got really afraid and and in the
morning they came and I heard them
talking at the table and they were
talking about having to take me to a
hospital
and they took me there and I go in a
room and
my mom was in the room and her head
looked like a watermelon she couldn't
speak
and the nurse came in and said what is
he doing in here get him out of here he
can't be in here and they said well this
is her son
and
so they took me out and then they pulled
the plug on her and they took me to the
scene of the wreck
and I get out of the car and I see
motorcycle parts and and I remember
feeling good I was like oh you know uh
my dad just got a motorcycle he had left
some of these parts and then I found his
driver's license
and I found a piece of my mom's shirt
that she was wearing and
and then it was like a realization that
this was the scene of a wreck and she
wasn't coming back and and so
um as a six-year-old who was mad at his
mom on Mother's Day
I I felt horrible because you know I I
kind of felt guilty that maybe I caused
it you know I'm
after that happened my sister she got to
live with the parents of my mom and I
got put in a house with the guy who was
our biological father
um
and I had to live I lived with him and
his dad and then there was some trailers
there where like some cousins lived with
their parents and
and um I had to do that for I was about
a year and a half there and it was it
was such an abusive place
um
I was electrocuted over and over
um he would take me into a shop
and it was his dad's shop and there was
a clown on the wall
and when they turned on a switch his
nose lit up red
and there was a wire about this long
underneath that
and when they wanted me to do the things
that there was three other boys in there
it was Dominic and Jeremy and Carl they
were my cousins
they would do things for him
and when I said no I had to grab that
wire
and it would electrocute me and then
when they did what they were supposed to
they got to grab me and grab the wire
and electrocute me again and again
and
I went through that for
quite some time as a child going through
that all I Learned was that what they
were doing was supposed to be done by
women not men and
you know my mom had told me about that
guy one time I was hiding in my closet
and um they were fighting and I could
hear it and I was scared to go out and
use the bathroom so I peed in my room
and hid in my closet because I was
scared and my mom found me and she said
I married a man or I married a mouse not
a man you're going to grow up to be a
man and you can become a lion because
Lions aren't afraid of that Mouse so
come out of your closet you're okay
and I mean those are you know some
things that I remember about my mom I
remember her having tattoos and
I I just remember she was such a good
woman and I knew that she was highly
abused and
and you know on on that day where she
died and I had to go look at that wreck
I remember feeling guilty because I was
so mad at her I wanted to be with her on
Mother's Day and
sometimes I felt like
maybe I caused this you know I was so
mad at her
and so
after being in this house with that man
who was molesting boys
on my birthday it was my eighth birthday
and his dad was there and and he told
his wife her name was Gail he said Gail
go get him his present
and the guy who was abusing us he said
you're going to become a man today
you're going out to that shop with me
alone
they brought me out a cupcake cupcake
had a candle
they lit it and I did my birthday wish
and I wished whatever was causing this
could stop and
his dad his head hit his coffee cup on
the table
spilled the coffee on the floor and they
took him to the hospital
and we didn't go
because my the man who called himself
dad to me said
you are coming out there with me now and
I said well this is something that women
are supposed to do and not men so can I
put on a dress
he said you've got five minutes to go in
my wife's room and you find yourself
something to wear but you better be out
in that shop
and I ran up I went in there jumped out
the window and ran away
um
being on the streets at a young age was
very hard
um
this is how old I was eight it was my
eighth birthday and I I found a guy
um he was he was probably 17 18 and he
he ran with a gang that called
themselves the insanes and he was the
only white guy and he had Whitey
tattooed across his forehead and he kind
of took me in and and
then I find myself living on the streets
with the gang who
if you stole
they would shoot you
um they they let me see a
they let me see a kid ask one of the
gang members asked another one for a
stick of big red gum
and he said I only have two left and he
went to put it in his back pocket
and it hit the ground and he started
talking
the kid who asked him for it walked over
and picked it up and put that stick in
his mouth
that that other one turned around and
shot him
dead
and um
that's what they did to thieves and so
when I was getting raised they said
you don't steal
and you stay in school
and that's kind of
you know I was in grade school living in
tents and
going and I would find a girlfriend and
she would let me come over after her
parents left for work and get ready for
school and
it's kind of how I did my my childhood
young ages and
you know I just
I was separated from my sister and you
know we were in different states because
she was still up there in Spokane and
when I had to move in with that man I
was living in Long Beach and
oh
um
so it was like a really traumatic
traumatic way of growing up um
I spent a lot of time on the streets
um
they taught me to
they had these little pills and they
called them cross tops and they would
say it was speed and they would give me
a bunch and say sell this at school and
sometimes in grade school I was
I was selling this stuff telling kids
it'll make you run the mile faster
and um
that wound up
getting me thrown out of a school in the
fifth grade and
huh
I just
it was it was a really hard way to grow
up
you know eventually I found a family
in Long Beach that
they were getting ready to move to a
town called Green Acres and it was near
Spokane
and when they were going up there buying
house and stuff like that
they they took me along I
their little sisters became like
girlfriends of mine and
they took me up there once and I was
able to locate my sister and
and I was able to get away from Long
Beach and these gangs and and get up
there to where my sister was and
it was a it was a really tough way of
growing up because by the time I was
sixth grade I remember I got put into
school up there and lived at the place
where my sister was
and
I was already selling drugs I was
I had I would leave and go live at the
cemetery where my mom was buried because
there was a castle up on the hill
and I had like there's a cemetery down
here and her picture was on her
gravestone
and so I would speak with her and then
I'd go up this hill and there was a
castle up there and there was like used
to be like a
a little maybe a pond or something but
there was no water in it but I would
play up there and stay in the castle and
and I I liked that better than having a
house I'd been on the street so long
um
my growing up as a childhood
I I never
I never really got that childhood I I
did remember that my mom had tattoos and
I remember when she came in my closet
and told me I married
a mouse not a man when you become a man
I want you to be a lion so you're not
scared of the mouse
and so when I when I was in kindergarten
I remember
my kindergarten teacher watched me draw
a lion and she said you are a really
good artist and that kindergarten
teacher was at my mom's funeral so
I
I really like that in in that that was
around the time where I decided I wanted
to become a tattooer I wanted to do
tattoos on people like my mom had and
and um so by the time I was in sixth
grade I had started tattooing on myself
and and some you know some people and
and kind of learning that trade but I
just I grew up so fast and so ah
um
and I mean by that time the family one
of the families who was going up to that
Green Acres they had moved up there from
Long Beach so now I knew people
from where I was out and and it was just
whoo
it was it was quite a way to grow up
so as far as parents
I I became one when I was
13.
um had my first
and uh now I'm I'm a parent of four kids
and I got a grandson he's nine now
I'm just
it's been
it's been quite a life as far as parents
go
how old are you now now I'm 44 I'll be
45 uh
next month January
did you did you raise any of your kids
yeah so
um my first two
um I was really a good part of their
life
um they moved to Portland Oregon and one
as soon as they moved there I I would go
there I I was homeless there for a while
and then I got a house up in Vancouver
Washington so I was close to them and
and I've always been a good part of
their life
um now my younger two and their uh
Shawnee she's 30 she'll be 31 here in a
couple months and then I have a daughter
Cora she's 24. and then now I have a a
10 and a 12 year old and they're up in
Spokane Washington and um
they're
I
they lived with me when I was up there I
have a house up there still but they
lived with me a lot and we did shared
custody and stuff like that but for the
last for the last couple of years I've
been back down here and haven't seen
them
so as of now I wouldn't say that I'm
being a great parent
um
my my older two
I was in a coma uh last year from
Thanksgiving day until February and they
came and saw me in the hospital while I
was in a coma and so I've talked to them
after I came out the doctors had told
them if we can't get them out of this
coma by New Year's he's going to be dead
and I didn't come out of it until
February so my kids all thought I was
dead so you know I I talked to the
younger two's mom and let him know and
and the older two I've spoke with on the
phone let them know like I'm I'm okay
I'm alive and
but I I haven't been seeing them you
know I've just kind of been down here
just
just pretending I don't even have kids
which is awful I but why were you in a
coma
um so on Thanksgiving
um
part of my
part of my thing that separated me from
the kids is drug sales
um
and
on Thanksgiving I had I I was down in
San Diego and I picked up a lot of drugs
and then I went to Oceanside and dropped
them off and picked up a bunch of money
and uh
so I'm on a bicycle with a saddle bag
attached to it and I had a lot of money
in there and
it's late at night and pretty soon a car
we're the only two people on the road
swerves across hits me on the bike
and so I'm laying my bikes maybe 20 feet
away from me and then the car pulls
between me and the bike and I'm thinking
okay he's coming to help and then he
hits me hits the bike hits me hits the
bike hits me hits the bike now I'm
when I come to he's over there breaking
in to the saddlebag
and I get up and start coming over there
and he turned around
stuck that screwdriver
right there
and uh it went into my liver
I was in the coma right there
um
he stole all the money
um I woke up in
I was right around Valentine's Day
um so then they put me in an Aftercare
home
um
and
I stayed there a little while until they
I had tubes in my neck and tubes in my
stomach and they cut the ones out of my
stomach
and I left
um
I left that day
still had a tube coming out of my neck
and I left that in for a few months
um
when I got it removed
which was it was around May where I
finally went in and had them cut it off
and
I said don't you glue this hole shut you
used to sew on my hair you glue them now
they said oh no we're not going to glue
that shut it's going to heal in a couple
hours don't worry
and here it is you know six seven months
later
[Music]
big hole
my liver's lost they said between 70 and
90 percent of its function
so I don't heal anymore
um
so now I'm I'm at the point where I have
to go in and if they have a cadaver
they'll cut some skin off of it and
patch the hole and if not I have to let
them cut some skin off of me somewhere
um and patch the hole uh
so it's just been kind of a
that's why I kind of got to sit here and
choke this because it's breathing and
it's just a but um
it's been
it's been rough you know I I I got
robbed for a lot a lot of money how much
money you lose 360 200 000 dollars
um it was a deal where we we stay up in
Woodland Hills near Calabasas and
the rent there was too much and the
girlfriend wouldn't leave and I'm just
kind of I don't even go home I don't
want to be around her because she's just
so into money and
so it was a point where we were going to
do like a seller financing the people
who we were renting it from wanted to
sell it and it was going to be a money
exchange so that we could Finance it
that way
they make a down payment it goes to the
seller and then the monthly payments
would go to my girlfriend so that she
could just go rent a house and not have
me pay for everything anymore because
you know things have gotten just rough
if you had 300 000
362 a bicycle why didn't you just
hire a cab or Uber or something like
that because I'm the reason I was down
there and with that much money I'm in
the drug selling world and
what I have to do to go get the drugs
and and I had already dropped them off
that's my biggest worry so I'm not gonna
do that in a car because I mean I I
travel around a lot and when you have
California plates you don't want to
leave California when you've got drugs
in your car I've been caught in Oregon
and in Washington with several kilos and
I just so bicycles is just kind of a way
for me to avoid that you know and I'm
trying to better myself and get out of
that hole you think we gotta hit you
knew what you had yeah um where I where
I purchased it there was a girl there
and she was a prostitute and she had
never been there when I was leaving so
she never really knew she was always
there
but when I would come she would try and
get me to buy her and I wouldn't and
that time when I left she was still
there she called someone and told them
he's going to be traveling through and
he has 100 kilos of heroin I think you
should and so it was it was a robbery it
was a robbery um
you know in the I mean I'll call it a
job the people I work for
they I paid up front so why not just rob
me and take it back is kind of how that
went
you know
and because of how you got it you can't
really report it to the police well he
um the person who did it I'm told
that I wasn't taken to the hospital in
an ambulance I was dropped off there in
a coma and so my thinking is that guy
must have dropped me off because there
was no one else out it was late at night
you know and
I don't think somebody just saw me
laying there I just I think he that I
don't know I like I said I was in a coma
for a few months and by the time I came
out my biggest worry wasn't about any of
that it was about my kids thought I was
dead
um you know and they visited me on
Christmas I guess and and that's when
the doctor told him if we can't get him
out of this by New Year's he's going to
be dead so my biggest thing was just
you know I I have a fear that my kids
aren't from California and my biggest
fear is
when I was young and my parents were
dead I wanted to figure out what was
going on and and my biggest fear is my
kids coming down to LA
and trying to figure out what dad's been
up to the last couple years before he
died I'm also in fear of
they find me dead they'll probably the
city will probably do a burning and
there won't be ashes or a cemetery for
my kids to visit and all that stuff is
the kind of stuff that I just think
about and I'm in fear of you know I I
mean that was important for me when your
parents die you sometimes have to go
talk to a gravestone to talk to them and
so I just feared that you know I
they were just that was the biggest
thing for me is just I got to deal with
this stuff with the kids and figure out
now
I don't know how much longer I have to
live I don't think long and now my fear
is what should I do should I go die
where my kids are
should I just pay for a cremation now so
that they can get ashes and necklaces I
I that's the kind of world that I'm in
right now and it's a hard place to be
but I just I don't want my kids down
here trying to figure out what I was
doing for the last couple years
because
La is
you know you can step in two circles
here you either become rich or you die
trying are you uh still using no
um so
heroin I was in a heroin addict for I
started when I was 13. and I was a
heroin addict for I think 27 28 years
um when I finally stopped I was using 13
grams of heroin a day which is a lot and
uh
finally
I just I remember I remember the day I
looked up the coffee maker
and there was a spoon next to it with
brown you know residue from coffee
and I was supposed to be making the kids
breakfast because they were running late
for school
and when I saw that spoon
all I could think of is
you don't need to make them breakfast
[ __ ] breakfast go get yourself well
and that was
something set it off and I stopped I
stopped using heroin at that time I've
used maybe three or four times since
then but I've been clean for years off
of it I I sometimes I'll smoke marijuana
still but not very often I haven't for
months now but I just I I got out of
that that world and now you know up
until a couple months ago I was a pretty
major heroin dealer I just came out of
jail yesterday for violating my parole
for heroin sales
um I didn't violate it with Heroin sales
I was on Parole for that
um I was I was up in Pelican Bay
um I think I got out in
19 or 20 and I just I wasn't checking in
when I was in the coma and so they
violated me for not checking in
um
and I just left there yesterday and now
that I'm out
I've made it a total decision you are
not a drug dealer you are not going to
Prey Upon people because that's what a
heroin dealer does I I go to places
where hookers are and hand out free
samples with my phone number I go to
strip clubs and
I pray upon weakness I know that if a
girl's doing that she needs drugs to
make it okay for inside herself and I
pray upon that and I'm I'm done I'm not
going to do that to people anymore
um I was at a point where I could have
hundreds of pounds of heroin and not use
it but I'm not going to pray upon weak
anymore
um I was weak and I was preyed upon and
uh not not anymore I don't care if I
wind up homeless I don't care if I don't
care I just I'm I'm out of the drug
world that's what needs to happen I'm I
need to grow up my mom told me to become
a man and a lion and I'm just a mouse
like that guy huh
so what are your plans now for your
future
so
I'm a tattooer and
here I at Rockstar studios here in
Chinatown I tattoo out of there
um
I have a tattoo shop in Portland where
those kids are and one of my daughters
up there you have to have a CNA to do
body piercing you have to be it so I put
her to school so that she could get her
CNA and she's been working their
piercing people and she when I just
talked to her recently she said I'm
making 500 to a thousand dollars a day
so that Shop's going to stay open
because I have a tattooer up there and
then my daughter is doing the piercing
and that's really good money I mean I I
wasn't even making that when I was
tattooing every day so so from here on
out I'm
I'm a steel stud framer I'm a concrete
worker a plaster a drywall taper
finisher uh spray
um I've done Roofing I I have a long
history of I have business degrees I
have graphic design degree
you know I can I can go anywhere I just
need to get my location I need to figure
out where I'm going to be because
staying here
I was here because of the drug world
because you can get it here cheap and
you can take it everywhere and make more
but
I think I need to get back up where my
kids you know I I'm not quite sure how
this is going to play out but I whether
it'll be Oregon or Washington but I
think I should be with my kids probably
my younger ones you definitely shouldn't
be down here no I I shouldn't that is a
former heroin addict this is this is
yeah this is one of the drug capitals of
the United States and the the cost of it
for me has become so cheap that it would
be hard it it's going to be hard not to
be a dealer it's going to be hard not to
start using because when you're away
from your kids and you love them it's
hurting inside and you know as a heroin
addict I know how to cure the hurt so
and it doesn't cure it it just puts a
Band-Aid on it and destroys your life so
I mean my oldest daughter
because my my younger the not my young
kids yet but my uh 24 year old she
gets into drugs and I have to go deal
with it my oldest she doesn't smoke she
doesn't drink she won't do drugs and I I
was talking to her recently and said how
what made you how come you're and she
says do you remember a house you used to
take me to he used to hit his wife
because he wanted to give you the money
not her and he used to throw her out of
bed and make people get off the couch so
we could sit down
she said I know what you were doing you
were selling them drugs and I don't ever
want to be those people
and when she told me that because she
was
she was little sitting on a diaper bag
with drugs and
I didn't realize at that age what I was
doing to her but it worked in a way that
she wants nothing to do with the drug
world and I told her I said you know why
I was selling those drugs you know I was
using them and she says yeah but you
didn't treat us like that when I saw
those people it made me never want to do
that stuff and so
there's a good and a bad
however the daughter who got left at
home
she uses she gets into all kinds of
things and so I don't know I can't say
that taking your child Along on heroin
sales is good but
for that for my oldest Shawnee it it
worked it made her hate it
um
and when I heard that it I guess it it
probably put a Band-Aid over the wound
that I had as being a 15 year old
setting a child on a diaper bag full of
drugs and taking her to places like that
that was but you know those insane guys
who who raised me
that's what it was you don't steal you
go to school and there was a point where
I had to drop out of school when I was
15 I found a place that if you got a GED
they would pay you to go volunteer
somewhere and at 15 I needed to get an
apartment because the mom and my first
daughter were homeless and I needed to
get them into an apartment and I was
only 15 so I went got a GED real quick
and I went to this place called City
stores and it was a warehouse that got
cops and firemen everything they needed
for the day
and I worked there and made minimum wage
but I was able to get an apartment for
that little girl who her mom was on
drugs because I was her drug dealer and
they got an apartment and now that Mom
is amazing she's done amazing things
that daughter's done amazing things and
I think it's time for me to do some
amazing things you know
um
you know that's if you had your life to
live all over again what would you have
done differently
you know to be honest
I look at people who never went through
the struggles that I did
and they have a different take on
religion and who their God is they're
taught in the church this certain way of
life
and me I remember being little
screaming at that God you created me and
you took my mom away you took my dad
away you put me on the streets I hate
you but then
after I'd be hurting on the streets then
I would be saying please help me through
this I don't have parents to buy me
school clothes God please help me help
me God and I developed a relationship
where
me and my creator
we speak
and God doesn't have a voice that he's
able to talk to me
but if I stop listening to my own
little navigation system and I just go
with what the Day brings I live the
story that my God created for me and
that story
introduces me to the right people
I'll be at the right place at the right
time
and life just is amazing when you live
the story that that Creator made
but every time I try and
navigate I wind up going back to
Childhood when it when a child started
becoming a man maybe 12 or 13.
I go backwards and so now I'm in a place
where
nothing nothing matters I I hate money
um
I don't why do I want to make all this
money destroying people's lives I hate
money money destroys you and so if I
just live my life I don't care if I
sleep on a street
because I have a loving relationship
with my Creator and a lot of people
don't have that they learned about the
book of the Bible in their own way they
probably don't even understand
Revelations when I read Revelations I
saw we're about chapter 22 that's the
whole Bible in one little book
and people just get stuck on this pray
to Jesus and
we don't pray to Jesus we don't ask
Jesus for forgiveness we learn to
forgive others
by knowing what Jesus did
we don't have to ask him for forgiveness
he was given up for forgiveness and once
you get to a level like that
you just go with God's story and
sometimes he makes a love story out of
your life and it's amazing he takes you
to the right people at the right time
it's been a really
it's been a really tremendous life I
mean some of the stuff that I have been
through
it
disgusts me but if I'd stop writing my
own story I don't think it would have
been like that so from here on out it's
just a
why go sell drugs and Destroy her life
so that I can have a fancy house
I'm fine I'll be fine like God will
always take care of me it doesn't matter
last night I slept
in a parking lot
because I had just met a man who
I asked him for a lighter because I
wanted to smoke a cigarette and just
left jail and um he gave me a lighter
and
everyone who takes the time to
speak to me and
I've been told dude you need to go to
Hollywood and get someone to make a
movie about your life
because when they hear about my life
they're just like whoa
but I think that having that tough life
that's what gave me a relationship with
God because if you don't go through it
you just you just take what the maybe
the Catholics teach and
you're fine I'll just ask Jesus for
forgiveness well no that's not what the
book says
the book says Be Like Jesus and forgive
I don't have to ask for forgiveness I
live in a world of sin but when somebody
steals for me
I have to forgive them
and that's the hard part but if you
really want to be
if you really want to take what God gave
his son he gave away his son
not to ask for forgiveness but to teach
us how to forgive
and that's my take on you know that that
part of it that's where I've developed a
different kind of religion than a lot of
people have I I believe in the Bible but
I just I know that the one book they
never taught me was Revelations and when
I finally when I came out of my coma and
God asked me
so can I have your son
and I said no God please don't hurt Ace
please just you can if you need a body
just take my soul
leave don't hurt my son and then it was
like God said wow you do know what love
was is
and then I realized my whole life I
don't know what love was I think you're
supposed to learn it from your mom
I don't I don't remember
learning it but I do know that I've been
married I think four times
I've been with women up and down but my
thing is I pretend to love them because
I want them and when a prettier one
walks by I don't want her no more I want
her I pretend love to her
that ain't love love is not about sex
with a pretty girl
because I love my children don't want to
have sex with them I want to
put them above myself if I got 10 bucks
in my pocket and I want something
I know that man my son really needed a
new binder for school
I don't need it here because their
future
is above me
and that's love and once I learned that
which was just recently
life has changed I meet people on the
streets and I love them
I love people
and when I start a relationship now
I had one girl say to me
are you trying to have sex with me I
said no I'm your friend and I love you
and when she was feeling this love she
started loving me back asking me to
marry her and have kids with me and I
was like whoa
where did this come from
she's probably never been loved because
I know I went through a life
Maybe
maybe 20 or 30 women
never loved them I didn't love them
because if I did I would still love them
so it's it's been a it's been a journey
it's been a journey but
you know I'm I'm really happy especially
so I just I think I was just in there
for around 60 days they gave me 120 days
so I think I did half of it and
and it was cool because
I remember for the last few days I was
there I would look over and I'm on a
bunk
and they call these the cut where people
can be right between two bunks and I
would look down and there'd be like six
people there sharing a needle shooting
up hey you want some
and I was able to say it's no
not only do I not want to share a needle
with about 20 people
I don't want the drugs I do not want to
get high I'm here because out there I
lose it I I go for money money money
money money and then I land here
I'm done here I'm too old to be doing
this I can't be in jails and prisons and
I'm done and so now hitting that
we had a guy doing AAA meetings and I
loved it I loved being able to give my
little parts of the story to people who
were trying to quit and then one night
he didn't have the AAA meeting I look
over
he's over there shooting somebody up
with whatever they had I think they had
a crystal or something
you're the AAA leader it just it was
like whoa I mean
I think it's finally a point in my life
where I can just
push all that stuff away and just go
maybe be the father that that my mom
said become a lion be a man not a mouse
I think I'm there I think I'm I'm ready
to really just be a man and you know a
man isn't away from his kids letting
them grow up without a dad he should be
there
you know my two older kids they have
houses I I got them houses
my two younger kids one of them is going
to have a house I let I let an old man
live there who lost his wife and had
some had some problems and they wanted
to put him in a home
so I said no you move into my house
we're going to remodel your house sell
it so that you have money
and we're going to get you a caretaker
so they live in my house for free so
that they care for him he was my
neighbor and he's a good guy
so that'll be probably my son's house
because he'll pass away before my my son
is 18 but
I just that's my thing is
take care of your kids don't ever let
them be like this out on the streets
um
so I don't know I probably veered off
the question not
seeing life
story don't you oh it you haven't even
heard the gist of it but I don't I don't
want to you know get too deep into
something because I don't even know if I
answered your question that's all right
Ellen thank you so much for sharing your
story and I'll get I'll I'll give you
anything I mean my story goes it gets
rough I mean maybe we'll have you back
again oh okay but uh I wish you the best
of luck now that you're out yeah I'm I'm
out and life is Gonna Change I do
believe life is going to change and man
oh
geez I remember being 13 and
having that first shot of heroin and
having two 20 year olds
have a threesome with it with me because
they came back into my life a couple
times later and
destroyed me
she was called Satan of Seattle and she
gave me a tattoo of the devil
with a needle in front of him that's
awful
it's it's awful in that life
so awful right I just I really hope that
Manny it could get better from here I
think yeah I think it can especially if
you stay away from the drugs oh yeah the
drug yeah the drug scene is is not the
place to be I
I just I can't believe how many lives
I've destroyed just for money
why
why does people do we get so addicted to
money
I mean here in California it's expensive
to live but
it's warm
if you're homeless it ain't that bad
I mean last night was pretty cold but
it's December you know I I think that
I think the changes of the utmost
importance
um
man
oh the place I've been I just
the DEA just killed my girlfriend the
one that I was
up there up there in uh
I got her in Livermore but we were up in
Woodland Hills and the DEA after they
arrested me they raided it and killed
her
huh
that's what I do to life
you know
ah the drug scene
we just we wind up dead or wishing we
were so awful
all right Alan thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you thank you
lots of lecture here
thank you